if you thought you were freaky dr.
faciliate just wait until you meet these
reimagine princesses
they'll give your shadow friends a run
for their money in this scary stage with
their ripped gown staring eyes and mean
sidekicks these ladies are ready to
scare all you villains into submission
you wouldn't want to meet any of them
down a dark alley late at night just
wait until you see what's eating
Princess Tiana talented artist Jeffrey
Thomas have given our favorite Disney
Princesses a sinister makeover in his
twisted princesses deviant art series
and they're giving us all the Halloween
fields keep watching to the end to
discover which princess has taken a leaf
out of Captain Hook's book rapunzel
Rapunzel used her beautiful long blonde
hair to heal but let's get real for a
moment hair that long is actually pretty
creepy and we could totally see how it
could be used for a bad purpose just
look at those hands pushing out from
behind the strands it looks like
Rapunzel has done some damage already if
perhaps she used her trusting frying pan
and just check out that mean look on
Pascal's face freaky fell what's more
disturbing than a twisted princess
looking you straight in the face a
twisted princess peeking out at you with
mean intent in her eyes Belle sure has
been through some scraps
judging from the rips in her signature
yellow gown she's also got a cord
wrapped around beasts neck but given
that it's ripped ooh it looks like this
beast is ready to pounce his eyes match
his mistress's gowns giving off a
terrifying look Cinderella it doesn't
get much more Halloween themed than a
pumpkin right and Cinderella sure knows
a thing or two about pumpkins however
instead of turning into a fairytale
carriage this one is oozing slimy goo
and instead of her trusty cute Mouse
friends cinders is holding a
mean-looking rat it's all creepy enough
as it is
without zooming in on her face she looks
like a scarecrow and what about those
buttons for eyes talk about channeling
the 2009 movie Coraline
mulan sinister eyes totally change a
princesses vibe just take a look at
mulan's glowing stared even moo shu has
a matching pair of peepers if you're
totally inspired by Milan's eyes you
could recreate them yourself this
Halloween with a pair of clever contact
lenses don't you just love how Mushu
seems to be appearing from a yellow and
red tattoo sneaking around Milan's arm
that's some pretty impressive body art
right there Aurora on the subject of ice
we don't even get to see Aurora's in
this twisted version and that suits the
sleeping princess down to the ground
however we do get to see her owls red
eyes and boy are they sinister as for
Aurora just check out how her black
lipstick matches her smudged mascara
trails you could totally try this look
yourself for Halloween it might be more
difficult however to catch the three
good fairies in a lantern let them out
twist it or aura Pocahontas
there's no mistaking what Pocahontas has
been up to her red stained body dress
and tools give that away and we love how
her usual outfit has been beefed up with
extra body armor you can easily wear
this look yourself for Halloween with a
pot of that fake red stuff splattered
over a Pocahontas costume getting an
evil looking miko and grandmother willow
to accompany you trick-or-treating might
be a touch trickier however Tiana
Shirley the freakiest makeover of them
all belongs to Tiana and that tongue
where do we even begin with this twisted
princess from her mottled skin to her
sinister expression Tiana is as
terrifying as they come
dr. facili has nothing on this
reimagined princess she's got his hat
his voodoo trinkets and his chilling
tarot cards she even has his startling
shadow hands sneaking up that creepy
creature it's also unsettling jasmine
speaking of the princess in the frog
just check out Jasmine's altered
earrings they've looked more at home in
dr. facili as voodoo shop than on
Sultan's daughter her signature outfit
is artfully ripped perhaps by the same
creature that gave her those scars
across her belly
and arms we can't imagine her faithful
pet tiger Raja would have caused the
blemishes he looks ready to defend his
owner at any cost and Jasmine looks like
she's ready to use that falling sand for
her own evil plans
snow white one look at this twisted
princess and the magic mirror will be
saying who's the freakiest of them all
this reimagined Snow White has black
pits where eyes should be her signature
pale skin has gone to an unworldly shade
of white and as for her red bow its
styled to look more like a pair of horns
but that's nothing compared to her
menacing crew of dwarfs with their
glowing orange eyes and spiky yellow
teeth they make the forest animals run
away in fear and we haven't even
mentioned that Snow White has them
tethered on ropes totally unnerving
Ariel step aside Ursula there's a new
underwater villain in town and she's
using her dinglehopper for no good in
fact it looks like that Fork is serving
as a hand eat your heart out Captain
Hook what trouble must Ariel have
encountered to lose that limb judging
from the cray smile on her face she's
beyond caring
Ariel's tail has dulled down to a grimy
ragged gray but her trademark red hair
is as bold as ever and as for flounder
we have no words we missed that cute
Guppies so that's a wrap on how your
favorite Disney Princesses got Halloween
makeovers
which twisted princess do you like the
most let us know in the comments thanks
for watching give this video a big
thumbs up and subscribe to the things
for more Disney Princess videos we'll
see you next time
[Music]